you know I want to look badass shrinking
this thing is white Russian but we got
these ugly green cuts good morning we
are in Dallas Texas we just got in last
night we are now visiting Casey's
brother's home cuz he moved out and now
we're staying in his old bedroom yeah we
are it's like your brother grew up so do
you give up this night he's always gonna
be like baby brother to me and so it's
really cool to finally see him do
grown-up stuff
you know in like yeah like the
difference between me and him is I left
home for school for college and he
didn't and so he never had a reason to
move out but now just with a H and
Mike's making money on his own like it's
too cool to see a friend you know Dubrow
enough things whoa is this there's a
leak Carrie morning welcome YouTube to
my crib it is nice this is ty islands
nice makes it feel like really upscale
oh yeah I heard you guys like clean like
crazy because we're coming over you
don't do that for yourself I do but I
mean I don't know
you get lazy and III I hear you it's
also like freedom of having your own
places like I don't need to clean for
anyone else yeah hi Ernie what's that
say right there
dumpling County cows eat how can you
have dumplings there I don't know I just
wanted a neon sign and then I found out
on Amazon and I figured you know that's
where we eat food so you know it kind of
matches you should better get another
one that says like tacos underneath it
you see it should be a sort of actually
she peed on everything over the door go
sir yeah whenever the I like the
fountain now is it a visual thing but
it's also like audio yeah like so
whenever I just have this door open it's
just real tranquil it's like a little
Zen garden out here the other side of
the pool I specifically requested to not
live by the pool now here's a noisy hit
parties and stuff yeah all right so we
are inside a relic a video store and my
brother just looking to opening a new
business and this is a spot he's
thinking about we'll bring this business
at and so we are location scouting and
to see if this is gonna be a good fit
for what my brother wants to do with his
business so we'll find out oh and also
this just happens to be Isaac's first
time inside a video store how do you
feel about being in a video store it's
cool yeah it's like a real-life Netflix
basically like Netflix in real life I
thought Netflix is more like internet
Blockbuster but now to be able to say
it's a real-life Netflix it's kind of
funny what's the last thing you was in a
video store a teenager I don't know yes
and I think the last movie never ever
went to a video store to rent was that
dude where's my car oh man I do remember
that my local videos so that I had been
going there since I was like 5 years old
I think for if I can I remember being
little like checking out all the VHS
tapes mana fuel I remember like wanting
to rent all the Barney ones for those so
into Barney without a little and then
like growing up I would just be like oh
now I can move on to like the bigger
kids section and then like
I grew up in that video story and then
to see like my own kid never experienced
that it's so weird you know baby back in
the day we had to get in our car drive
to a video store Oh No spend forever
trying to pick which movies you want to
rent and then you take it home you get
to watch it and then you have to come
back bring it back in two or three days
you get charged like a leafy yeah before
the DVD days you had to rewind every
tape - and then I remember when they it
came out with Netflix in the beginning
the only service they had was for them
to send DVDs to your house I was like
this is awesome that I think good of a
video story that didn't last long either
streaming took over streaming but you
have a good man you know you're still
looking at this generation it's so cool
you don't have to look at a phone book
you don't have to look at a dictionary
every map you don't need a map yeah
what are you trying to play I don't know
but why are you talking about I believe
it's these two keys right here
yes do you know what the left hand does
[Applause]
when it goes down right now go down to
the white notes chicken chicharonnes
alright so now we are at my family's
restaurant and V Bella cafe saw Sarah
check it I haven't had again in your
local to Dallas area sorry I'm slurring
a little bit already
I don't drink usually but when we do
come to Dallas though that's when we go
ham on some drinking so we're surrounded
by family so we're able to let loose for
once and plus you guys like it
anyway though we should just blog and
drink more pictures
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's Christmas Eve and we're about to go
eat dinner let me know lunch lunch with
the family so we're heading out of town
tomorrow on Christmas Day which means
we're not gonna be home for Christmas
Day which means if there's Christmas
festivities we want to do we would have
to do it today like Mexican most Mexican
doing today yeah that's true
I always knew I was in the gags on that
rocket you wrapped your own first
Christopher yeah I wanna wrap one of
them but then there are other tents too
and I didn't have to wrap this our
presents are like family members brought
presents over from their house and I'll
G under the tree and I was so useful
I would end up eating
like
that kind of contractor myself is I'm
like a I wanted to surprise but it
wasn't gonna be surprised you're the
handle it
I couldn't useful if I would Philippine
you can't handle the surprise so now I
look I try not to like grow and spread
like sometimes when you're setting
something up and I could be the tail and
like seize up to something like oh you
just
when did you ever realize that I was
setting something up over everything you
saw but what did you see that I know I
couldn't you know what so when I was
planning the reservations for his
birthday the missed my call whenever
whenever I was trying to get the book
the reservation and they called me back
a couple minutes later and when I called
him initially I found like a pocket of
time when tiffin Isaac we're downstairs
I went to the absurd bathroom to make
the phone call when they call me back
tiffen Isaac were upstairs and I think
it was vibrating on the table the the
phone call so it was kind of like well I
think she heard the phone ringing so if
I picked it up and went somewhere else
and hid away and had a conversation it
would be really weird I guess I was just
forced to have the conversation then and
there but I was trying to avoid key
words like birthday or reservation or
party of nine but I said I heard like
the key words but I knew you were so
nice I tried to like tune out so I
didn't even know I was really surprised
in my room I remember I remember my key
I remember me making paper airplanes oh
yeah that's right I don't thing to do
but yeah I mean mom you were in a room
and let words
and I kind of overheard reservations
did I have any talents on Barney tells
on telling ya that's not talent this
just tells it's a wrong tail - it's not
tail it's tell ya - Oh Nichelle's on
Christmas plans at all actually I guess
one thing their vote conversation over
[Music]
olá smacker
[Music]
we're getting fat oh yeah I need it do I
need it yeah you need it - you're
signing us Ronnie I'm gonna walk up
dirty style
[Music]
so the holiday drink for this year is
actually it's the same holiday drink
every year seems like White Russians
[Music]
I like that seat cushions we got and I
brought them you like ya throw back
pillows from like the 90s that we still
somehow have here at this house your mom
knows how to take care of yours oh yeah
all right so what are you about to do
right now Christmas Eve dinner or
technically Christmas dinner kids we're
celebrating Christmas okay yeah so
tomorrow we're going to Houston and
we're celebrating we're getting all our
Christmas celebration done on Christmas
Eve this is our Christmas anyway
yeah the Mexican way you know the way
you've been to my family we've turned it
back to me
but we've also that's true that's true
when it breaking the Christmas tree no
actually it's better I think as you get
your presents sooner if you wanted a
Christmas day you're gonna have to wait
till tomorrow market go to fish tonight
thinking about what you're getting is
stuff y'all anxious yeah you only have
to wait like maybe another hour or two
now all right cheers everybody
[Music]
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas the star
of the appetizer show right now is the
abalone my dad has made that baloney
like four years in a row we've been back
in Dallas to celebrate Christmas four
years in a row and every year he's made
abalone so
this has become a tradition of its own
how is it Baba softer it is the moment
you've been waiting for sir four hours
seconds two minutes means two hours
hours today spaced weeks so we just
spent like 30 minutes trying to organize
this slow it makes a better story thirty
minutes yes hour maybe even Oh photo
right no it just means that we wanted
that perfect photo no yeah okay maybe it
took like maybe you closer to five
minutes maybe nine and ten
what about to do now present can you
pick up the first one please no you're
gonna be last because they're so eager
in them if you wait even more oh that's
it you get for a scare
you guys ready to haul a might quite
layman you know what I'm open presents
oh yeah how do you say that in Spanish
everybody if and I got a little bring it
around bring it around for no one
what is that it's a Gryffindor pen and
Gryffindor Harry Potter and then what's
that what's that indoor notebook no but
you're a wizard Harry because the movie
who said to use the wizard of course
that's some fancy journal right there I
said Wow
I want you to be all filled out with
words when your own handwriting by mixed
Christmassy our after-school program
they were having that to raffle off oh
really
yeah well I really wanted to get out
like now you've got it buddy look at the
cool box yeah let's keep this pen at
home yeah you're not thinking that's the
school buddy from us fragile
what does fragile mean to you what do
you think what do you think what is that
it's a one if Harry's wand Harry
Potter's one
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so my brother has the Sirius Black Monde
right yeah and she's got a snake or vice
versa oh yeah it's got the Snape in the
serious black one and Isaac's been
playing with that those two wands like
crazy since he's been here
now he has his own Harry Potter wine you
know what he said he said that he wants
us to buy the Hermione and Ron to the no
three of us have our own water oh yeah
so is my me Hermione then and I'm AM Who
am I never run alright you see Harry
Potter stuff is quality for detail oh so
cute the other night - I thought cute
like music mommy does he do it like oh
you got to stand up for this when people
do one of the professor's he does this
and the other first fessor which is like
very message asleep he doesn't this Oh
wondering if he does that like that yeah
you should have your own style what's
the Isaac style alright simple let me
give you a scar on your forehead el Dia
de los Muertos four times a charm
because enough
the NBA
[Laughter]
[Music]
cool be nice love you and always and
forever love RAM and RAM RAM aka hey now
you know how to read it in Chinese I
don't even know how to write those nice
[Music]
educational gifts this yeah very
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
boy over to drunk now you drunk big boy
[Music]
[Music]
what that it occurred have a new aging
Asian character that's right cuz I think
it's Peruvian that's right Oh peanuts
[Laughter]
[Applause]
anyway Sophia day Ruby a bride
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
really good I was trying to do kids and
if you don't like the fur cause I had to
ask you if you like fur or not I found
one where the fur is detachable hey it
looks pretty good oh is it yes part all
part of my genius plan
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a clever finger tithing right
there
[Laughter]
[Music]